i'm going to now direct this advice
president biden
i do not believe you are a racist and i
agree with you
when you commit yourself to the
importance of finding common ground
but i also believe and it's personal and
it
was actually very it was hurtful to hear
you talk about the reputations of
two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race in
this country
and it was not only that but
you also worked with them to oppose
busing
you know there was a little girl in
california who was part of the second
class
to integrate her public schools and she
was bused
to school every day and that little girl
was me
vice president biden do you agree today
do you agree today that you were wrong
to oppose busing in america
do you think that his remarks about
segregation as senators
and his past policy on busing
effectively disqualify him as a
candidate
that's a decision for the voters to make
it's hard to pick somebody that's that
disrespectful when
she said things during the debates
during the
democrat primary debates that were
horrible about
sleepy joe and i would think that he
wouldn't have picked
and i am with great enthusiasm i'm going
to endorse
joe biden for president of the united
states i believe in joe